- This week on Couch Tomatoes,
we're talking The
Mandalorian from Disney Plus
and giving you our Fresh Picks
on what else to watch on TV.
Hello, hello friends.
Welcome back to Couch Tomatoes
sponsored by Freschetta pizza.
I'm your host Naz Perez.
And today, on the show, we're diving deep
into the first live-action
"Star Wars" series.
It's called the Baby Yoda Show.
I'm just kidding, it's
called "The Mandalorian"
but we're definitely talking
about Baby Yoda later today.
And here to help me talk
about it is the author
of "Why We Love "Star Wars"", Ken Napzok,
Collider's Perri Nemiroff
and Fandango's film and TV
correspondent, Nikki Novak.
Hello, hello.
- Hi!
- Hello!
- Guys, I gotta tell you
I'm so happy you're here just
'cause I'm a prequels lover
and kid at heart so I feel
like much to learn I have,
I am but a young padawan,
amongst your presence, Ken.
- No, I love it.
I actually coined the term
Prequelist and we are strong.
We are those you who look
past a lot of silly things
to find the themes that
George put in there
and those things are
present in The Mandalorian.
- Wow, I feel like I've
just been knighted by you.
Okay, guys let's jump right in to it.
In a galaxy, not that
far away from our couch,
The Mandalorian is set
five years after the events
of Return of the Jedi and the
fall of the Galactic Empire.
And we know the show
follows a lone bounty hunter
known as The Mandalorian.
Now, Ken if you're fan of the films,
we know Jango and Boba as bounty hunters.
We're familiar with them
but is there anything about
The Mandalorian's that we need to know
or should know going in
to this that's out there?
- Well, the first thing
that you should know
is that Jango and Boba
aren't actually Mandalorians.
They are accused.
Jango's been accused of stealing the armor
and running around pretending
to be a Mandalorian.
Now, that could turn out to
be something totally different
but the culture is very war-like.
They love their violence
but then Duchess Satine,
during the Clone Wars
era, believed in peace
and started a movement of peace
and that kinda became the culture.
There's a lot of pride
and honor in that outfit,
in those armor, the
armors of The Mandalorian.
- That's really interesting
cause I feel like most people
are just categorizing "The
Mandalorian" with Boba and Jango.
But what I love about this show is that
the creator Jon Favreau
and the EP, Dave Filoni
has said, that you don't
need to be a "Star Wars" fan
to jump into this and
hop on the bandwagon.
But what are you guys loving
about the show so far?
- I couldn't agree more
with that statement.
I mean, that's one of my
favorite things about the show
to start is how narrow the focus is.
As much as I love the galaxy far far away
and all the possibilities there are in it,
the fact that we have
this one main character
and we're getting to,
I mean, essentially live
with him for a little
and experience his day to day life.
I feel like that's part of the reason
the show's kicked off so strong.
- What I love about it is that
it really does have its own feel.
Although, it's steep in
the "Star Wars" universe,
there's a hundred thousand
Easter eggs for people to find,
it really does feel like its own thing.
I love that it just kind
of unfolding slowly.
You know, I remember
from "The Force Awakens",
you jumped right into the action,
this, sort of like takes its time
and you're really getting
invested in the characters.
- I love it and we were
actually talking about earlier
how I love the fact that it's episodic.
So, it comes out week to week
and I just feel like
"Star Wars" is an event.
We wanna talk about
this stuff week to week.
And Nikki and I actually sat down earlier
and had the ultimate debate
on whether it's better
to binge an entire series
or watch it week to week.
Take a look.
So, Nikki, today's show got me thinking
about how I like to watch shows.
Do you like watching one episode a week
like the good old days
or do you like binging an
entire season in one seating?
- Oh, binging for sure.
I'm way too impatient
to wait week to week.
I love seeing everything in
one seating, how about you?
- I actually like watching
one episode a week
because I feel like it gives me something
to look forward to.
But I also love just
inviting friends over,
tossing in a pizza and then
talking about the episode
with them after.
- It makes way more sense
than the way I do it.
(laughing)
It makes it more of a
group experience, more fun.
- It does and it doesn't
have to be anything formal.
Whenever they come over I
love serving Freschetta pizza
because they have so
many different flavors
so, I'm able to mix it up
and make the episode special.
- So, what are you serving
this week and am I invited?
- You are always invited.
And this week, I am serving
the gluten free pepperoni.
The pepperoni is so good
and zesty and no joke,
the gluten free crust tastes
just like regular pizza.
- I want it now.
Can we just have it now?
- Let's dig in.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- All right guys, so at
the time of this recording,
we've all only seen two episodes, so far.
If you haven't seen Chapters
One and Two of The Mandalorian,
this is your official spoiler alert.
Chapter One is 88% on the
Tomatometer, 39 minutes long.
Chapter Two, 93% on the Tomatometer
just a short 32 minutes long.
Which brings up an interesting question,
is "Star Wars" better in smaller
bites or on the big screen?
What do you guys think?
- Look, "Star Wars" is
an epic event, right?
Even Bob Iger talks about
keeping that intact with movies
But the audience's,
what we want out of
stories now has changed.
I always look at shows, go
back to "Lost", "Sopranos",
"Game of Thrones" is the big
example of we wanna take time
and they're forcing us, as fans,
to take time with these characters.
You're talking about binge or not.
It's like, they're like, nope
you're gonna have patience.
You're gonna enjoy this
story over the course
of short little bites and it's working
and I never thought I'd be
saying that as a "Star Wars" fan.
- I thought it was really
interesting when the first episode
when I start press play
on the first minute,
it's so beautiful and
it has a cinematic feel.
I felt like, oh my gosh, you poor thing
being seen on this little screen,
you deserve a big screen
in this cinematic.
But that's what I love about it
is that it is cinematic quality
but we can take the time.
I mean, we just want more "Star Wars".
So, I think, whether
or not this turns into
then a film adaptation, I think
it's all good, it's all up.
- It's the best time to be a "Star Wars"
fan for that reason.
We get the best of both worlds.
We still have films on
the way, eventually,
after "Rise of Skywalker"
but now, we're gonna have
all of this Disney Plus
content to fill those gaps.
And the idea of having these mini stories
with the same character so far are proving
to be extremely effective.
- [Naz] Right, it gets
you even more excited
and us even as "Star Wars"
fans are learning more sides
to this story we didn't
even for example, Baby Yoda.
Let's talk about the little
green elephant in the room.
This thing is so cute, I
don't know if I wanna eat it
or punch it in the face.
- We know what it wants to eat
- It is the cutest thing I've ever seen
in the entire world.
- It wants to eat frogs.
Which I did not appreciate that,
it's my biggest fear in life.
- I was dissecting--
- You lost me there.
- The whole time, I'm like,
oh is that how it gets its green color?
What do we know about the Yoda species?
- Wait, I wanna know Nikki
are you afraid of frogs
or eating frogs, which is the bigger fear?
- If you put one on the table right now,
I would be out of this room.
- Oh well.
- It's my biggest fear.
- We need a Baby Yoda around to eat it.
This has been fascinating.
The show went in a real
interesting direction
to be like, oh you thought
it was just gonna be about
a Mandalorian bounty hunter
in the underworld of "Star Wars".
No, this has ramifications
for the franchise.
Ramifications for the fandom.
I really think this is gonna lead
to us learning the biggest
secret in "Star Wars"
which is Yoda's species.
And I didn't expect that in
a live action "Star Wars".
We're focused on other
things and then this pops up.
And there's a place for
cute in "Star Wars".
- Yeah
- There always needs
to be cute.
- I'm excited to dive
into theories with you guys
but before, I just wanna know
what your initial thought was
when you saw it, was your mind blown?
'Cause people are going crazy.
I mean, the internet is
calling it Baby Yoda.
We obviously don't know if
it's even related to Yoda
but what were your thoughts
on it when you first saw it?
- You never know though.
I think the timeline
could kind of work out
for it to be related to Yoda.
But I remember sitting there
watching that first episode,
big smile on my face from start to finish.
I was absolutely loving
it particularly the stuff
with the IG droid towards the end
but what took it from like it to love it
was the second I got that shot,
that reveal at the end,
that this character exists
and the way, that they've
kind of opt to that character
through episode two, that opens the door
to so many possibilities and I
think it's also possibilities
that could not only affect
the show going forward
but also maybe, "Rise of Skywalker" too.
- Yup.
- I think, it's the new Baby Groot.
Maybe, he is the new Baby Groot.
It's that universal, is there
anybody that doesn't love
what we're calling Baby Yoda, for now.
But I think in episode two,
what I really appreciated was
seeing that relationship start
to build with the Mandalorian
and how he's this warrior stoic character
and Baby Yoda is giving these looks
and trying to help him and heal him
and he's just not having any part of it.
It was really intriguing to me because
what I love about "Star
Wars" is the relationships
and that relationship to me
is so intriguing right now.
I can't wait to see Baby
Yoda break him down.
- I know, break him down.
Well, you brought up how
he almost try to heal him
which we haven't seen The
Force ever heal someone.
We're only two episodes in you guys.
Let's talk about theories,
speculation and expectation.
Let's start with this Baby Yoda thing
'cause Perri you brought up a good point,
this could affect "The Rise of Skywalker"
And the way that this show,
the way that the episodes
of "The Mandalorian" is
releasing syncs up perfectly.
Episode Seven comes out
the day before "The Rise of Skywalker".
Episode Eight comes out a week after.
Is this Baby Yoda gonna
bring balance to the force
and maybe defeat Emperor Palpatine?
- I don't know
- Like what's happening?
- I don't know if I'm willing
to go that far just yet.
But the fact that the run
of the show does bleed
into that movie, that's kind
of what you gotta do right now,
to play the game and to battle
all the other franchises
out there is have that connectivity.
They're doing it with the
Marvel shows on Disney Plus.
It would make sense for them to do it
with their "Star Wars" shows as well.
When "Rise of Skywalker" is supposedly
about finding balance in the force,
having a character with force abilities
like this Baby Yoda has already showed us.
Also being of the Yoda
legacy to some extent,
whether this character is
actually related to Yoda or not,
that does seem to be like that key
that could be missing especially because
when we left these main
characters in "Last Jedi",
their forces were greatly diminished.
They could use the help
and it seems like Baby Yoda
can be the one to swoop in
and maybe not save the day
but lend a little hand.
- And I was surprised
to see him use the force
in episode two but
let's go down that road.
What are your speculation, expectations,
do we think this is a
clone 'cause Dr. Pershing
had a clone emblem on his
suit, what do we think?
- I am very intrigued by the clone aspect
and the clone angle thing.
But Dave Filoni loves putting stuff in
and he's been helping craft
this show with Favreau.
I think Dave likes to just drop
things into the canon water
and be like, have fun with that.
But the idea, is it related
to Yoda, is it Yaddle's?
Did Yaddle and Yoda have
some, break some Jedi codes?
(laughing)
All I know is that, the
theme of a Mandalorian,
who's an orphan himself,
connecting with this orphan, now
is gonna lead us to somewhere.
I just don't know if JJ
Abrams and Chris Terrio
are watching that to figure
it out or were aware of it.
So, I'm open to the big theories.
- Do you have any theories, Nikki?
- I kind of concur with the two of you.
I don't know, I think the
cloning thing is an obvious,
that we're all gonna talk about
and then it's gonna end up
being, yeah sorry, I know
that's what you thought but, no.
We're not gonna make that easy for you.
- The Kamino patch is
such a big deal though.
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- And also because it's not
the only place we've speculated
about possible cloning too.
It's like, the Luke hand, the Rey thing.
That's been a big theory
that's been floating around
for quite a while.
If that doctor appeared in
"The Mandalorian" when he did
and had that kind of conversation
and has that kind of investment
in bringing back Baby Yoda alive,
one would think that he would want to do
what his old facility used
to do and clone a force user.
It seems like such an
obvious path to make.
- I'm becoming more
intrigued with who else
is sending the other bounty
hunters after Baby Yoda.
- [Naz] Like IG-11.
- IG-11, the Trandoshan
brothers, for all I know.
- Yeah.
- They all have a tracker.
Who else is sending it?
I don't think it's just The Client,
Werner Herzog's character.
I think there's someone else there.
That's where my theory mind is going.
Who knows, maybe Boba
Fett is behind it all?
Just like, you know what,
I'm still in the game.
I need this big score, I don't know.
That's pretty exciting for me.
- That's another theory
running in the internet too
is people say, you know, Boba died.
He fell in the pit but we
never actually see him die.
Is it possible that Boba
Fett is The Mandalorian?
- No, I don't think he is The Mandalorian
but in modern canon, in the
"Aftermath" novel series
by Chuck Wendig, you'll do learn the armor
is there in the Sarlacc pit.
A character named Cobb Vanth
takes it and puts it on
but there was no body, so, who knows?
- Ken, I'm glad brought
up the "Aftermath" Trilogy
so for those of you guys watching,
they're a set of novels
that take place between
"Return of the Jedi"
and "The Force Awakens".
Do you think that they're
taking any other source material
from those books and
putting it into the show?
- I think they're taking
the tones and the themes
and the world building.
I think what's going on in this,
we're five years after Jedi,
the New Republic's trying
to figure out what to do,
Mon Mothma's trying to
de-militarize the New Republic
and that's kinda gonna help lead the rise
of these people looking for identity.
This show's about identity.
The empire needs identity post fall.
Cara Dune is a rebel soldier
who needs an identity without a war.
He is a bounty hunter
who needs his identity
back as a Mandalorian.
And I think, that's where
some of the bigger things
will come out of the show.
- "Aftermath" is a great read for anybody
who hasn't read those books.
But I don't know how much they're pulling
from the books, specifically
just because they never
really have to a degree,
as far as new characters
and new information goes.
But I don't know, I'm semi-entertaining
the Boba Fett idea, even though I.
If I had a bet right now, I would say,
no, he's not Boba Fett but
there are certain things
out there that do align quite well.
The time period is very very appropriate.
So, it could, the fact that
he falls into the Sarlacc pit,
the armor does still exist
but even if it was chewed up
he would need new armor and
it does kind of look like,
we already saw them replace
the shoulder with the Beskar
so he does clearly need new armor
so it could have been
because of that event.
- And I heard we learn
more about the Beskar steel
in the third episode from
friends in the building
that have seen it before.
Have you guys seen the third episode yet?
- I have not.
- Not yet.
- I need your friends.
(laughing)
- I feel like the third
episode's a turning point
that all of us on the
couch have missed out on.
- Well, let's talk about
other things that we do know.
We know that this Baby
Yoda is 50 years old.
Ken, where would that put it?
Was this thing born before
"Phantom Menace", then?
- Could be around that time.
The "Star Wars" math.
You're 25 years away from
"Revenge of the Sith",
which means you're there, you know,
you got about 15 years going
back to Phantom Menace.
My "Star Wars" math gets a little fuzzy
but it's around that time.
- [Nikki] I'm glad you did the math.
- Yeah, I didn't do it well
but it's around that time.
- What about other great
characters we've seen?
Do we think IG-11 is gone for good or--
- We were talking about that
before we were theorizing.
I mean, you have Taika Waititi.
You have one episode.
Instantly, the second he
came on screen, you're like,
need more of this but it's
just like them to say,
especially Taika and
knowing Taika's personality,
no, we're just gonna give you a bit.
I know you want more but
no it's not gonna happen.
- That would be such a shame.
That fight sequence was so good.
And the IG droids are just,
they're so visually stimulating.
It's so much fun to watch them in action.
Maybe we'll get another IG droid.
It doesn't have to be IG-11.
There are other bounty
hunter droids out there,
who knows maybe we can
get a different one.
- Can I have a selfish
question to all of you guys?
Are his eyes like what he shoots out of?
This bounty droid, I'm
like, where are his eyes?
- I'm trying to, see we're all learning.
Favreau is been writing
the series since the 80's.
He dumped his can of figures on the floor
and said what if, what
if, and that's where,
we're finally getting to see
an IG series move like we have
'cause in "Empire Strikes Back",
it's a prop, sitting there
that's just, you can't move it, so.
The fluid, the movement,
he has some character
in those eyes, I wouldn't say no.
I wouldn't trust that droid
to not shoot me from his eyes.
(laughing)
- And Carl Weathers' character Greef Karga
mentions a smuggler and the
way he says the word, smuggler
makes me think, are we
gonna get a Han Solo cameo
in "The Mandalorian",
what do you guys think?
- I would say no, at this point.
I have a feeling that's not gonna happen.
Now, that I'm saying that,
I'm thinking about the swell of support
for Alden Ehrenreich to
return as Solo at some point.
But I mean, it would kind of make sense
because we're on an outer rim planet
and he could be out in that region.
But I still think that it
goes back to what we're saying
at the very beginning of this episode,
that one of the main benefits
that they have right now
is how contained this world is
and how unique it makes it
feel while also maintaining
the pillars of what make
"Star Wars", "Star Wars".
I think it would be in their benefit
to play in that little sandbox
for a little while longer.
- Let's talk about Easter eggs, guys
'cause there is a lot of them in here.
So, what have been your
favorite Easter egg
so far, in the show?
- For me, it was the No
Disintegrations thing
which, you know, Vader says to Boba Fett
in "Empire Strikes Back",
and you just kinda grow up imagining
what that might be in your head.
And even though again, not
necessarily is this is Boba Fett
but the weapon comes from Boba
Fett's holiday special weapon
so to see it and I feel
sorry for those Jawas
but it was so cool.
Like I feel sorry for them but I was like,
do it again, do it again!
- The jawas had like
the worst brunch ever.
That egg, I was like, what?
I thought there was gonna be
something so cool in that egg.
It was like mac and cheese
or something.
- Something magical
- I think the Kamino patch is still my top
because I didn't know that.
And then, I think it was a Reddit user
that first found it and
I'm like, you're right!
And that could change everything!
And I freaked out.
But also, just seeing the
Jawas get so much screen time
because that was always just
like a very visually pleasing character.
I like cute creatures too
and they're cute and I
like the noises they make
but we only got the tiniest
little taste of them.
And now, all of a sudden,
in this one episode,
we see the inner workings
of the Sandcrawler,
so many little features
that we never knew before.
And like yeah, laugh at the egg thing
but that was clearly something
that was very important
to this epic "Star Wars" race
that we never really knew before.
The fact that this series
is giving us a little time
to live with not just the
Mando but others as well,
yes, I want more of that.
- I know.
- I love the use of Carbonite.
I was saying that in Empire,
I watched that as a child
and it terrified me, the
use of Carbonite freezing
and the fact that they brought that back,
I thought in the first episode.
And yeah, to me,
that was just all that
"Star Wars" nostalgia.
It was like a little extra
and I can't wait to see
how they're gonna use
it more moving forward.
- I know, I love the frozen Carbonite.
I wish I could freeze my own body
and then, hang it on the wall.
I always thought it
looked so cool. (laughs)
But I have to ask you guys,
'cause I know you said
there's no better time than
to be a "Star Wars" fan
but is "Star Wars" fatigue a real thing?
- It's not for a lot of
people because I think
there still general audience
who just likes to take it in
as part of an entertainment buffet.
I think that there's some
truth to that a little bit
but I mean, I got "Star Wars"
pins on my jacket, I'm okay.
But I'm not the general
audience so, I don't know.
- Maybe, I'm not the
general audience either
but I don't feel it in the least.
And I'm someone who is going
out and watching the movies,
watching the shows, watching
the animated series,
I read a lot of the books, I love it
and I love it because the world is so big.
Yes, the Skywalkers
have been our main focus
for a very very long time
but there are so many little
corners that really now
at least on the wider scale,
we're finally exploring.
I definitely highly
recommend people to check out
the comics and the books to
find out those little nuggets
that they might not have seen before.
- I think that's what
this show is showing you
is that there are so many
more nuggets to explore.
So rather than being
fatigued, it makes me go,
oh wait, they could also
go in this direction
or this direction, I think
there's just even more now.
- Well guys, we are just barely
scratching the surface here.
Obviously, we could go
on for hours and hours.
So, hopefully we answered
some of your guys' questions
if we didn't, maybe join
Bob Iger's masterclass,
maybe he'll answer them
for you guys. (laughs)
But I can't have you leave
without giving me your Fresh Picks.
So, these are just shows
on TV that you are watching
that you think people at
home should tune in to.
- All right, are you ready?
- Yeah!
- This is weird.
- Okay?
- I love watching British gardening shows.
- Yes!
- What? (laughs)
- You need to watch, "Love Your Garden"
with Alan Titchmarsh
over there in England.
He goes to people in need
and re-does their garden.
And if you're not crying
by the time the sunflowers are
growing, you're not a human.
And I watch that all the time.
And then, "Monty Don" which is like this,
he's this professor, wears
like a cardigan and boots
and then he goes in the
yard and British gardens
and just, I'm obsessed with it.
- I was not expecting
to hear that from you.
Where can we find "Love Your Garden"?
- Netflix has a run on it and
the "Monty Don" stuff too.
- I have a question, if you
had to choose between that
and "Star Wars" what
would you choose? (laughs)
- You know what, we all
need to love our garden
- Wow!
- I have a little Death Star planter
that I won't be able to
grow for the life of me,
maybe I should gift it to you.
- Death Star planter (laughs)
- I swear.
I bought it at "Star Wars" celebration.
- That's the great gift for you.
- My pick is, a YouTube
original show, it's "Impulse".
And it's basically the show
that they said was a
spin-off from "Jumper".
And yes, it is to a degree
but it's a completely
different set of characters
and it handles that ability
in a very unique way.
But it's got one of the best
lead performances I've seen
in a new show in years,
her name is Maddie Hasson.
She is phenomenal in it.
So, it is a show with a super
cool supernatural ability
but what makes that come
out of her in her real life
she's capable of doing that
is a very traumatizing experience.
It's a very dark show
and she handles that emotion so so well.
I think she is gonna be
one of the next best things
but until she gets more
and more opportunities,
I think "Impulse" is well worth a watch.
It's a great show across the board.
- And on YouTube.
- Yes on YouTube.
- Amazing, thanks Perri.
- Nikki, what are you watching?
- I think mine is as much
a "Star Wars" departure
as British gardening is.
I chose "Dickinson" which is on Apple TV
and Hailee Steinfeld, who
I think did a great job
in "Bumblebee", she's the lead in it.
It's the story of Emily
Dickinson but it's told
in a very very modern way
and with modern themes.
And it's one of those, there's 10 episodes
and it's just easy to binge.
Like I found myself on episode
10 before I knew it going,
how did that happen?
It's very digestible.
- Yeah and I love that
all 10 episodes are out
for that one now.
- Yes.
- Well, since we're talking about
"The Mandalorian" on Disney Plus,
I am obsess with "The World
According to Jeff Goldblum".
I can watch this man do anything.
The first episode is about sneakers.
He dives into the world of
sneakers and I love sneakers.
But there's a part in the episode
where he just plays street basketball
with these basketball players
and I feel like I'm watching
my dad try and go at it
and it is just worth the
money of Disney Plus alone
to watch Jeff Goldblum
try and play basketball.
- I heard somebody say,
you don't learn anything about sneakers
but it's fascinating
to watch Jeff Goldblum
be fascinated about sneakers.
- Exactly.
The whole time, he's just
like "Wow, wow, wow!"
I'm like dying laughing.
- There's like a weird
money deal that goes done
at that sneaker convention he's at.
- Sneaker-Con, yes!
- Yeah.
And just witnessing it,
it's one of the weirdest
wonderful things in TV.
- Yeah, I've been there.
Buying the kicks.
All right guys, well that is our show.
Again, thank you guys so much.
Thanks to Ken and Perri and
Nikki for joining me today.
For more on "The Mandalorian",
head on over to rottentomatoes.com
and comment below
and let us know what you
think about the series so far.
Also, don't forget to
hit that subscribe button
and notification bell so you don't miss
any future Couch Tomato episodes.
Next time, we'll be talking
about Apple TV Plus.
We'll be diving deep into "Dickinson"
and all the other shows.
I'm Naz Perez and I'll
see you guys next time.
(upbeat music)